Feel the clarity
and Live Claritin Clear.
>> Tucker: FACEBOOK'S ENTIRE
BUSINESS MOD IS BUILT ON
HARVESTING YOUR PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
AND YET SOMEHOW BLUE CHECK
TWITTER JUST LEARNED THIS
TODAY AND FREAKED OUT WHEN
THEY FOUND OUT.
CAMBRIDGE ANALYTICA, U.K. DATA
FIRM HIRED BY THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IS MIRED IN A SCANDAL
AFTER A WHISTLE-BLOWER CLAIMS
THE COMPANY MISLED FACEBOOK
USER TOES COLLECT THEIR
PERSONAL DATA.
THAT SOUNDS SPOOKY AND IT WAS
KIND OF SPOOKY, ACTUALLY.
WHERE IT WASN'T THAT SPOOKY
SIX YEARS AGO IN 2012.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION FOUND
ITSELF CONGRATULATED BY THE
MEDIA FOR HOW IT GATHERED
FACEBOOK DATA IN ORDER TO
MARSHAL VOTES.
ONE OBAMA ADVISER SAYS
FACEBOOK LET THEM BREAK THE
COMPANY RULES BECAUSE, "THEY
WERE ON OUR SIDE."
BEVERLY HOLBERG IS PRESIDENT
OF DISTRICT MEDIA GROUP AND
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.